but if the last seven days have been
tumultuous the next seven are going to
be critical it's going to be a
make-or-break week not just for the
government but for the country well
joining us now to discuss that is the
prime minister Theresa May thank you
very much for being with us it's been a
difficult week should we say
you've lost seven members seven members
of your team including your Brett
secretary we've seen Conservative MPs
parading letters of no confidence in you
in front of those TV cameras have you
ever thought at any stage about just
giving up what's the point of this no I
happened and of course it's been a tough
week actually these negotiations have
been tough right from the start but they
were always going to get even more
difficult right towards the end when
we're coming to that conclusion but what
I think is this isn't about me it's
actually about what's right for the
people of this country it's about what's
in the national interest that's what
drives me and that's what I'm being
driven to deliver that's what I want to
deliver for people and that's what I
believe this deal does I think it is the
right deal in the national interest and
these next seven days are going to be
critical they are about the future of
this country it's about people's jobs
it's about their livelihoods it's about
the future for their children and
grandchildren you said there that it's
been a difficult week I mean that's
quite an understatement really at one
point it looked like the whole house of
cards could come falling down but you
did manage to hang on to some of those
crucial brexit a cabinet members people
like Michael Gove like country legend
but they seem to be saying that they'll
only stay if there is more movement on
the deal you can have a look at
something that Andrew led 'some said
yesterday she said there is still more
to be done and we do still have time
before the EU Council is she right is
there any space for more maneuver well
there's there is indeed more negotiation
taking place and nothing is agreed until
everything is agreed but perhaps I could
explain the the nature of the deal
because actually there are two parts to
this deal there's what you Mike might be
called the leaving part of the deal and
then there's the future relationship the
future deal that we're going to have
with the European Union what that future
deal does is delivers on the vote that
people gave us in the referendum in 2016
it delivers a brexit that bring
back control of our money our laws and
our borders it means we bring an end to
free movement once and for all for
example no jurisdiction the court
European Court of Justice that's the
future that delivers on brexit for
people there's been some controversy and
concern about the leaving part of the
deal and about this thing called the the
backstop or the insurance policy for
Northern Ireland but that will only be
temporary what is going to determine our
future relationship bring that end to
free movement and that court
jurisdiction of the Court of Justice is
that future part of the deal these two
go together and we won't agree on you
know we won't agree withdrawal the
leaving part until we've got the future
part well let's let's be clear they
because you said there that there's some
more space for negotiation is it the
leaving part that's done and dusted it
is the negotiation going to come when it
comes to what is written in that future
declaration well the as I say we won't
agree the the leaving part of you like
that was the withdrawal agreement until
we've got what we want in the future
relationship because these two go
together is they focus the focus the
focus this week will be on the future
relationship and when we were in the
House of Commons a number of members of
parliament were saying we want some more
detail on that future relationship
that's what we're working on this week
but it's the future relationship that
delivers on the brexit vote it's the
future relationship that actually says
this is the right deal for the future of
our country because it's out deal that's
in the national interest in the
interests of people up and down this
country worried about their jobs and
worried about their children's future
it's been two years to get to this point
so you're really saying that you're
going to change the future relationship
deal in the next seven days that's a
pretty tight timetable but over the two
years there's been a lot of negotiation
a lot of the negotiation has focused on
the withdrawal part the leaving part and
just to give an example Sophie right at
the very beginning I said those people
from the European Union living here in
the UK and UK citizens who are living in
the other 27 countries of the European
Union we need to make sure that their
life choice is protected their rights
are protected so there was early
negotiation on that for example what
we're now focusing on is getting in that
X more detail on what the future
relationship will
so that we make sure that we deliver for
people that's what yeah that's what this
is about
what are you delivering brexit for
people what are you gonna do then in the
next seven days it's not not we will be
negotiator I'll be going back to
Brussels we will be negotiating there
when we came back to Brussels
well the negotiating teams are working
as we speak and obviously which day I go
back to Brussels when I go back we'll
determine how the but partly be about
how those negotiations go so I will be
going back to Brussels I'll be in touch
with other leaders as well because the
summit next week and it is next week
this special European Council will be
among the European leaders who will you
be meeting in Brussels well I I want to
meet will meet jean-claude Juncker and
sit down and talk to him he's
responsible for the Commission side of
the obviously and it was a rural
agreement on the table when you have
that meeting the withdrawal agreement as
we agreed to withdraw our agreement in
principle on last week the withdrawal
agreement goes alongside the future
relationship it's the future
relationship that actually delivers if
you like on people's concerns in the
withdrawal agreement getting that future
relationship right it's necessary
nothing's agreed until everything is
agreed I understand you came to talk
about the future relationship but if you
look at the two documents the future
relationship and and the divorce still
if you like the withdrawal agreement if
one is 585 pages long the other is seven
pages long one is meticulously detailed
the other one is fairly vague there's no
legal commitments in there I mean do you
ever worry that unique of being played
here that the EU has asked you to hand
over 39 billion pounds on that on a few
can fake promises no there's a there's a
reason it may seem a boring reason but
there's a reason why there's a
difference between these two documents
and it is we can't actually sign up to
that detailed legal text indeed
negotiate not sure that you could indeed
negotiate much of that legal text until
we've actually left the European Union
and if anybody's in any doubt we are
going to leave the European Union on the
29th of March 2019 so what we need from
that future relationship is an agreement
from between us between the UK
and the European Union that this is what
that future relationship is going to be
and if you just look think back to where
the European Union started on this they
wanted us as a country just to take an
off-the-shelf model that the phrase in
your Norway or a Canada style treaty for
Great Britain only not for the whole
United Kingdom we fought that we stole
our ground we said no we're the UK
actually we can have a better more
ambitious relationship with you that
will be good for citizens good for
people here in the UK and I think good
for people in the EU as well and it took
it took time but they have come around
to that and they've said yes we'll agree
a more ambitious relationship with the
UK than we at further you at first
thought we could give you know I do want
to focus a little bit on the backstop
because this is effectively why you've
lost your bracelet secretary this week
lots of people are very concerned about
it and just one part in particular of
that withdrawal agreement that I think
we can have a look at so the withdrawal
agreement says the backstop can only be
brought to an end if the Union and the
United Kingdom decide jointly that it is
no longer necessary to achieve its
objectives I mean this is what Dominic
Rob was concerned about isn't it this
idea that we can't unilaterally decide
to leave the backstop it's a bit like
the Hotel California you can never leave
no you can leave okay well first of all
let's let's look at what this backstop
is the backstops an insurance policy the
backstop is saying to the people of
Northern Ireland but it might have
Ireland no I know you didn't want it
happen but it might but look if I can
just explain because there's difference
the various stages in this there's an
assumption that somehow this is the only
option on the table and it's not and
that's the first thing that's important
to for me to say to you now this is an
insurance policy it says that if we get
a come to a point in time where the
future relationship that we're
negotiating can't be fully in place by
the end of December 2020 and we fully
intend to ensure it can be and that's
what we're working to but if there's a
short period of time when we need this
insurance policy we need to make sure
that people of Northern Ireland still
have the real
have no hard border between them and
Ireland so we've got two options at that
stage and we can choose whether to have
this backstop as it the phrase has come
in to normal common parlance or whether
to extend the implementation period for
a brand I don't wanna back up stop if it
ever happens the issue is about being
able to leave you know that really I
mean we can leave the EU and actually
buy 20 nautical 50 it's about
sovereignty well I think as you've just
seen from two years of negotiations on
the withdrawal agreement for us leaving
the European Union but yes there was an
article there to leave the European
Union but it's about a negotiation
between both sides as to how that is
going to be done that's what we've been
entering into so in the backstop there
will be a review of the backstop and
both sides can say yes we agree that
there are arrangements in place that
deal that provide for the people of
Northern Ireland and therefore that the
backstop is no longer necessary can we
really know that backstop yes or no they
aren't coming but Sophie just think
about if you had took out an insurance
policy and if you were coming up up to
the point where that and that insurance
policy was being used and suddenly the
people providing that insurance policy
pulled the plug on it for you and you
were left without that insurance policy
without having any say in it what would
you what would you think so you've
actually actually what we're talking
about is a backstop we never intend to
use me you don't want to use it either
it's not the only option that is on the
table were it to have to be used it both
sides can review it and the process by
which we can prove that actually there
are other arrangements in place so the
backstop can be stopped and the backstop
can only ever be temporary under the
legal arrangements of the European Union
they cannot enter into a permanent
relationship on the basis of this
withdrawal agreement
it can only be temporary and then that's
why I focus on the future relationship
because the thing that's going to make
the difference to people's jobs
to people's livelihoods to people's
futures in this country is the future
relationship we negotiate with the
European Union that's what we must put
front and foremost that
in the national interest to get that
deal right to ensure that yes we're
leaving the European Union we can have
those trade deals around the world we
can bring jobs to this country we can
make that better future for people okay
now I'm no mathematician but I don't see
how this deal can get through Parliament
labor has sent that they want to vote
against it the do you pee who said
they'll vote against at the SNP the
Liberal Democrats dozens of your own MPs
it's not going to get through with it
oh look when it comes to Parliament
members of parliament we'll have to look
at the deal but I think I've as I've
previously said I think they should also
think well this is about this is about
delivering on brexit it's about ensuring
that we deliver what people in this
country voted for I know that's that's
that's not gonna get through Parliament
right now the when people come to look
at this deal that's what they need to
think about but let's look at some of
the positions that you've said other
parties have taken and jeremy corbyn in
the labour party jeremy corbyn is clear
he's gone to a vote vote against this
whatever
he hasn't even fully read it he doesn't
even know what's fully what's in it and
yet already he's saying he's going to
vote against it why because he's playing
party politics with this this isn't
about party politics this is about what
matters for this country it's about what
is in the national interest that's what
I'm determined to deliver a deal that's
good for the people of this country what
happens if it doesn't get through
Parliament would you be prepared to
bring it back for another vote there's a
there's a process that Parliament will
go through if were it the case that the
deal was lost then the government would
come back with their proposals for what
the next step was but we're not at that
point we're at the point of a week's
further to go in the negotiation when we
have that agreement with the European
Union at the EU Council and bring it
back to the House of Commons what I'm
saying is I think every member of
parliament will want to look at the deal
but they want to ask themselves how can
I make sure that we deliver brexit and
how can I do it in a way that's good for
my constituents and remember there are
those in the House of Commons who just
want to stop brexit I believe it is
essential for people's trust in politics
and Trust in Parliament that
deliver on brexit for people now this
weekend your future is hanging by thread
conservative MPs we know submitting
letters of no-confidence to the chair of
the 1922 committees to Graham Brady if
that reaches 48 there will be a vote of
no confidence in your leadership when
was the last time that you spoke to so
Graham Brady
oh I spoke to Graham Brady at the end of
last week so do you know if you have
each I hate regular conversations mr.
Graham rating but let me just reach the
point it's just just as Graham Brady
will make it known if 48 letters are
reach Graham Brady will make that know
do you let me just just I have not as
far as I know know the answer your
question is no but it is sorry just the
answer the question is that the 48 limit
has not been reached as far as I know no
it has not but let me just address this
issue about the the question of
leadership as I say to me this isn't
about me it's actually about what's
right for the country and as far as I'm
concerned I'm not going to be distracted
for actually the important job in this
critical week of negotiations of making
sure we do get that final good deal for
the country but you know a change of
leadership at this point isn't going to
make the negotiations any easier and
it's not going to change the
parliamentary arithmetic what it will do
what it will do is bring in a degree of
uncertainty that's uncertainty for
people and their jobs what it will do is
mean that it is a risk that actually we
delay the negotiations and that's a risk
that brexit gets delayed or frustrated
I'm clear people voted for us to leave
we will leave and we'll leave on the
29th of March 2019 now the last week
that must be have been personally very
difficult for you and we can have a
quick look at something that your Chief
Whip said a message to some of your MPs
the prime minister will not be bullied
and will not change course do you think
some MPs have been trying to believe you
and what was your message be to them
look this is an issue on which people
have had very strong views some of them
have held those very strong views for a
very long time we're coming to the point
at which some difficult decisions have
to be taken about how we ensure
that we deliver brexit for the British
people I think you know obviously people
have been making their views known and
that's understandable
we live in a democracy but when it comes
to it I ask all of my colleagues to
think about this to think about ensuring
that we can deliver brexit for the
British people to think about ensuring
that we do it in a way that is good for
our constituents not some debate in
Westminster you know it's very easy in
Westminster to get involved in
intricacies of debate and and not to
remember that actually what this is
about is not us it's about people out
there it's about their few you say it's
not about ours but at the same time your
leadership is in a critical point right
now and I am interested in the impact
it's had on you personally because some
of the language we've heard some of the
enormous briefings in recent weeks have
been frankly pretty horrific we've heard
talk of killing zones of nooses of
assassinations I mean how does that make
you feel well first of all I I think all
of us in politics have a responsibility
to make sure that when we talk about
things we do so responsibly and we think
about the sort of terminology in the
language that we're using but look it
doesn't it doesn't distract me from the
main task at hand and that's why I come
it's the well look bothered politics is
a tough business and I've been in a long
time so I've seen the ups and downs of
politics I've seen the sort of you know
and I've been through some tough times
myself in the past in politics I always
think the important thing is to say what
are we here for who are we here for and
we're here for our constituents as Prime
Minister I'm here for the people of this
country and that's what we must put
first and foremost their interests
that's what miss drivers it's what
drives me is what's going to drive me in
the negotiations over the next week
after in a week when people have been
queuing up to criticise the decisions
that you've made that they believed that
you were going down the wrong wrong
track and for better or worse I just
wonder what it is that makes you keep
going I mean in the past you've spoken
about your father's sense of duty
museums of Vicar as your faith helps
well that's a part I mean that isn't
sort of integral part of me if you like
but
it's it's what what drives me what keeps
me going in this is knowing that
actually we have a I think we have a
duty as a government I think we have a
duty as a parliament to listen to people
if you think back pre the 2016
referendum Parliament overwhelmingly
said this must be a choice of the
British people and we gave people that
vote
and they gave us their vote and they
said let's leave and I believe it's
absolutely critical that we do that and
we can have you know debates within
Westminster
about is this the perfect brexit from
one person's viewpoint or the perfect
brexit from somebody else's viewpoint
what matters is that we deliver brexit
and what matters is that when people
come to look at this deal and vote for
it in Parliament they recognize the
importance of ensuring we're delivering
brexit and don't we I don't want to risk
ending up in a situation where brexit is
somehow delayed or people try to stop it
from happening we are going to deliver
for people we're going to leave the EU
and that's gonna happen next March and
then just finally Prime Minister there's
been some studies over the years that
have showed that in good times companies
they're more likely to appoint men to
leadership positions but in times of
crisis they're more likely to appoint
women what if you know yes I haven't
seen that research so I don't know what
the what the basis of that research is
look I think all I would say is that I
look at this as a politician as a member
of parliament as a prime minister and I
would as I do I will hope that every
other member of the House of Commons
will think not about themselves not
about the theological arguments of
brexit but actually think about what
matters for people up and down this
country let's give them give them the
certainty of that bright future that's
delivering brexit on a good deal
that's this deal okay big questions
there for all MPs they're coming up here
Prime Minister thank you much for being
with us this morning